and be going at it with karl-anthony  towns and the bench is empty my goodness  by the neck towns is hot  he's in front of his bench  and I don't know what precipitated this  but you have to think both  for the rest of the game  [Applause]  it was Simmons on the last play with the  Sixers on defense see him right there  was ghetto and then indeed came into  double-team and those two remain in the  backcourt this is what ensue  [Applause]  Pangos right after that  and then indeed came in to double-team  and those two remain in the backcourt  this is what ensue  [Applause]  Joell and pain goes right after  [Applause]  Joell having some words with Mike Scott  Wow  [Applause]